Alberto fujimori back in front of a
judge but this time peruse embattled
former president was testifying by video
link from prison the 84 year old is
accused of causing severe injuries to a
large number of women and in some cases
death as part of a sterilization program
in the 1990s
the accusation is false because what my
government did was offer the population
and women in particular all the modern
and traditional Family Planning methods
without exceptions or preferences
leaving it to the free choice of each
woman concerned
nearly 350 000 women and 25 000 men were
sterilized as part of the program
fujimori says it was crucial to reduce
maternal mortality rates and cut poverty
but women's and Indigenous rights
activists have long fought for
accountability
it's part of white Nanny protested
against three presidential campaigns by
fujimori's Daughter Keiko
they say many of the women couldn't
understand what was happening or were
targeted because they were poor some
women tell of being threatened with a
fine or prison if they didn't comply
the judge outlined the allegations
the reproductive health program and
Family Planning was applied disregarding
regulations the adequate infrastructure
the specialized medical personnel or the
informed consent of the people
fujimori is a divisive figure in Peru
considered by some a corrupt dictator
While others credit him with ending an
economic crisis and defeating the armed
group The Shining path
he was extradited from Chile in 2007 and
is already serving a 25-year prison
sentence for human rights violations the
latest hearing is to decide if he can
face trial for the sterilization program
given that it wasn't mentioned in the
extradition papers
the case has taken years to get this far
and there's still a way to go but the
women affected say they've waited
decades for justice and they won't give
up until they get it Alexa Brian Al
Jazeera